morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy wednesday it is hump
day and i'm so excited to be sitting
down with a woman i like to hump on the
daily
taylor striker hi taylor shreker hey
girl hey hey go ahead i'm so excited to
be here you know this is my favorite
place to be it truly is are you still
feeling insecure about your hey girl hey
we talked about that on your podcast i'm
over it i love it and it's the best and
now i i have something i have to ask you
what how would you feel if i change it
to hey girly girl hey
no
first of all girly girl is my thing i
know and i [ __ ] know it and second of
all like don't mess with perfection hey
girl hey like it's truly perfect okay
thank you i will get off my job
oh my god i'm so jet lagged i know okay
well so
first of all taylor is here she's one of
my favorite co-hosts host of the taylor
schrecker show on patreon she does a
daily show also you're so funny
you know what's so funny every time you
come here you like have to be like a
publicist for the vanderpump rules crew
and
it's unfucking believable your timing is
impeccable i'm actually on the schedule
for over a week like like for real yeah
and now you're just coming here on the
heels of major vanderpump rules news i
know it's our top story today i know you
just got back from la hanging out with
the vpr crew yeah look before we get
into tommy katie how's the vpr galleys
doing they're so good um so stassi and
bo that's like obviously who i'm staying
with the whole time so actually i had a
gift
for you specifically from beau so stassi
from his bow dossie is a daily listener
of the morning toast now you know what i
i did know that yeah and we're hoping to
secure her um for a guest co-host when
she comes to promote her book she was
talking like she was definitely gonna
come down oh my god i can't believe but
she was like i'm nervous because now i'm
like a fan
oh my god the thing is is that the
morning toast we i don't know if you
know this but we recently found out that
kylie jenner listens to the morning
toast shut
the [ __ ] up it's like ninety percent i
kindly no it's like it's 10 conspiracy
90 facts i think it's facts no we like
know but like we're not like a hundred
percent sure but like we know um tell me
how you know i'll tell you later okay
honestly obviously you don't listen to
the toast because we've been talking
about it all week
i'm a little busy doing two hours i
can't believe you do two hours a day i
can't either honestly like even in l.a
sauce is like you work too hard yeah
totally so
who knows what the future holds but for
now two hours daily it's um it's not
video it's audio but you should check it
out but she started listening to she's
like you know her book's coming out
she's like kind of like ready to get
back into the world and so she said that
her first foray was we just i was on her
patreon she just talked about it january
1st of 2022. she told herself i'm going
to start listening to podcasts again
that are like not just like true crime
and history and [ __ ] like that and so
she started with you guys
wow that is so flattering and she's like
a big fan and she's also listening to
taste of taylor which is my support um
but it's a big thing to like listen to
your friends yeah and enjoy it i know so
anyway but so she was listening and she
has just like on in the house and you
guys are talking about the rams before
the super bowl oh yeah and so beau sent
me home with a rams champion hat for you
that's actually a hilarious hilarious
which i [ __ ] left on my kitchen table
you're such a dope like
i mean do we want to talk about our text
exchange trying to confirm today uh you
were i was gonna post it you're the you
should you're the only person on the
planet who doesn't respond to a text
message for hours like that's insane
claudia i live
in the moment no you don't every time
i'm with you on your phone
such a truce
no i'm only on my phone with you guys
because you guys are all on your phone
and i feel uncool okay don't play paris
hilton project don't project your
insecurities onto me [ __ ] okay no
no i am like
when my phone's down my phone is down so
you were in la i know you were like
batch recording podcasts like back to
back to back doing all this stuff like i
just wanted to confirm you you were the
last one to confirm before i could post
the schedule get the toasters excited
well i when i saw the schedule go up
immediately after i understood
the anger the deep rage i was like
are you like it's one thing not to
answer for like 20 minutes 30 minutes
like four hours can i read it yeah it's
like really i i was gonna get really
[ __ ] but then i was like wait i'm
scared of people
i think she's being too big of a [ __ ]
no you can post it okay so basically
okay okay taylor okay when are you back
this is uh friday at 3
24 p.m
when are you back i'm scheduling you for
wednesday on the toast does it work for
you at 5 23 two hours later two hours
it's actually a lot one hour and 59
minutes later two hours okay
taylor in all cabs [ __ ] if you don't
answer me
and so
my wife texted me oh i also texted your
wife and i was like tell your bitch-ass
wife
to [ __ ] check her phone so anyway i
got tased first and i was like [ __ ] so i
wrote god i'm sorry and then claudia did
you finally respond huh what time did
you finally respond [ __ ] two hours
later
okay okay and then she just goes
wednesday question mark and i said yes
to me back wednesday exclamation point
and then she wrote great in all caps bye
i guess if you don't know me like that
does sound rude
but like i am just like i'm all business
you know i know you're this woman no and
i and i respect your boss business vibe
and you look like a boss business lady
today you look stunning thank you
where's this outfit from let me guess
sarah okay top is zara yeah shoes are
zara
um ring is my ex-husband
and then the pants are [ __ ] fabletics
wow and i am ready and i am here from
thank you you look great i like you and
neon thank you so much i don't look as
great as you so anyway i forgot your
present i'm sorry it's okay
i'm sorry but stasing beau say hi oh my
god i cannot believe stassi is like a
morning like a routine listener like
she's yelling me and jackie a few times
about things we spoke about on the toes
yeah she was like but i didn't know that
meant like homegirl was tuning in every
day you just love to see like women
lifting up other women yes right so
they're great they're getting ready for
the wedding i am so i announced
[ __ ] do i do it [ __ ] it do it so it's
coming out like in two weeks on taste of
taylor should i just say there is an
announcement about the wedding [ __ ] you
no i'm gonna give you i'm gonna give you
first hand tom and katie [ __ ] so i'm
saving this for me taste of taylor
there's an announcement about
stassimbo's wedding that we talk about
on taste of taylor and do i know what it
is yeah yeah i think you do so should i
blurt it out don't you [ __ ] dare
but i have to get a really great dress
for it yeah and so i'm like [ __ ]
panicking about it you're talking a lot
about it i think people are going to be
able to guess well they can guess okay
but if they want to come from it taste
of taylor taste of taylor so you're
joining me today co-hosting with the
toast we're going to dive into the fast
five obviously i really want to pick
your brain about tom and katie because
i'm like left here like devastated with
my heart and a million i'm really sad
too um and it's also wednesday which is
our deer toasters day where people write
in for some advice and for some reason
you randomly have co-hosted like five
wednesdays in a row and i think you give
really good advice just because you've
lived like a really interesting life
thank you and i think you've like made
mistakes and built yourself up many
times both personal and in business so i
feel like you actually offer like
wise wisdom i am incredibly wise thank
you which is actually code for old which
i also am
and um no but i just feel like i can
really see the world from like
everyone's perspective almost now not
everyone's but like a lot like even like
my dad i feel like i get his vibe for
the first time in my life so yes thank
you i'm great advice it's to share that
i'm here it's be shared i'm so excited
that you're here thank you for coming
thank you and i'm really excited to just
like poke and prod you for questions so
i think we should just dive in let's do
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
zip recruiter ziprecruiter uses its
powerful technology to find and match
the right candidates up with your job
then it proactively presents these
candidates to you you can easily review
these recommended candidates and invite
your top choices to apply for your job
which encourages them to apply faster
their technology at zip recruiter is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post unzip recruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
and according to the latest research
ninety percent of employers plan to make
enhancing the employee experience a top
priority in 2022 after all a happy
workplace is key to attracting and
keeping great employees find the right
employees for your workplace with
ziprecruiter try it for free at this
exclusive link
ziprecruiter.com toast that's zip
recruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
today's episode is also brought to you
by framebridge which is personally like
a favorite sponsor of mine i have so
many frame bridge items in my home and
also frame bridge is just reinventing
the framing industry because the framing
industry is archaic so frame framebridge
makes it easy and more affordable than
ever to frame your favorite things
without ever leaving your home you can
add a gallery wall to your home office
you can send the perfect gift from art
prints and diplomas to the photos just
sitting in your phone you can frame
bridge just about anything here's how it
works go to framebridge.com and upload
your photo or if you have a physical
photo they'll send you packaging to
safely mail it in preview your photo in
dozens of frame styles and gallery wall
layouts then you'll choose your favorite
or get free recommendations from their
talented designers the experts at frame
bridge will custom frame your item and
deliver your finished piece directly to
your door instead of the hundreds you
would pay at a framing store their
prices start at 39 and all shipping is
free plus our listeners will get 15 off
their first order at framebridge.com
when they use the code toast so you can
order online at framebridge.com or you
can stop by one of their stores in new
york dc atlanta philly boston or chicago
get started today frame your photos or
send someone the perfect gift go to
framebridge.com and use the promo code
toast to save an additional 15 off your
first order
framebridge.com promo code toast frame
bridge.com promo code toast if you've
moved into a new apartment a new office
it's like the perfect way to personalize
your home and it's so affordable like
framing does not need to be so expensive
i don't know like why these framers have
been acting out of control for years
okay so let's dive into the past five
obviously the thing on everyone's mind
people magazine vanderpump rules tom
schwartz and katie maloney split after
12 years together
although we may be on different paths
they say we will continue to love and
support one another's happiness thank
you for all the kind words so they both
post there was like a bunch of rumors
floating around yeah like break that
down so i have known about this for
a couple weeks now
and it has like been an ongoing thing
like i don't even think i was privy to
like the length of time that this is
going down and but having
having been married before
and then like going through a divorce
and separation i actually like i know
how it goes down and it takes it does
not happen overnight it takes it's a
crack and then it's a full you got it
okay okay so
there were rumors going on about and
honestly i didn't really believe it
because when did the rumors start like a
couple days ago yeah and i was like oh i
just wouldn't talk to anybody i know you
were in l.a and then i saw your stories
like weren't you with them both so this
is the thing is like it really is
amicable and it's not [ __ ] you know
and so it's like i know congresswoman
coupling blah blah blah but that's like
gwyneth and i actually do love gwyneth
now but i would take a bullet for her
right but she can be a little
um like it's just so easy i woke up like
this vibes and it's kind of annoying
yeah but in this case i mean they are i
can't even like talk about the bubba of
it all because it like breaks my [ __ ]
heart i know but like this is
they are still like socializing together
like we were so the news so i knew about
it like a couple weeks ago and then when
i got out there
we had dinner me and stassi and katie so
of course like we like talked more about
it but like i even kind of felt like
maybe i felt like as somebody who loves
a relationship like i was like is there
a world in which maybe there could be is
like a trial or something and who knows
what the future holds is i guess what
i'm trying to say
but like i also like but that's the
thing about relationships you never like
nothing is ever fully set in stone you
never know so i was just kind of like
trying to be supportive and not like
stick my nose in too much yeah of course
because it's so hard especially when
you've been together for so long and
especially when your relationship has
been on national television for so long
and people just love to criticize yes
and tom and katie like have been the
butt of a lot of jokes yes which is just
annoying and now i think like people who
you know are like trolling them online
we're like we we knew we were oh which
is just like such a [ __ ] annoying
thing to say so i do have to say i was
left kind of breathless by tom
schwartz's statement yeah which was just
shocking to me because first of all he
kind of
let us know like katie's the one leaving
him katie's the one who's decided this
marriage no longer works yeah she's no
longer happy yeah which i love because
i think we've seen on the show for a
while on the show is not everything but
like she deserves more and she deserves
better yeah and she's just been like you
know miles ahead of him when i think
when it comes to like maturity
absolutely and so i thought this was
such a mature statement i'm gonna read
it because i was like not to be dramatic
like i was breathless i was like i was
too okay so this is what it was too well
this sucks how am i supposed to capture
12 years of love in a [ __ ] canned
instagram caption what picture am i
supposed to use is there a go-to breakup
font i wanted to clear the air on some
of the rumors floating around katie and
i are separating i'm not quite really
used
to the d word yet
because it's too painful yes my heart
aches but i'll be okay not looking to
evoke any sympathy here i'm not the
victim not gonna write a sad to not
gonna write too sad a song i fully
respect katie's decision and we've had a
healthy productive conversation about it
it would be far sadder if she decided to
stay with me while not happy after nine
years on reality tv show it feels a
little tone deaf to say please respect
our privacy right especially while
posting this so instead i'll ask you to
please be kind i don't judge you for any
snap judgment
if i was watching us on vanderpump rules
for the last nine years i'd be making
them too right perception gets skewed
because of seeing snippets of our lives
on the show but i'm telling you we had
some of the most blissful romantic fun
times
humanly possible over the course of our
relationship i'm talking heaven on earth
level of joy i know oh man i'm like
literally gonna cry i need to she taught
me so much about love and being a better
partner it's hard not to feel like a
statistic another failed marriage i
don't look at it as a failure as sad as
i am still happy to say there's no anger
or bitterness zero still so much love
for you katie and your family i don't
think we were ever a model couple maybe
we are a model divorce a dubious title i
suppose also i'm aware of the tragedies
taking place in the world right now i
have perspective i'll be fine so i'll
shut up now and say it one last time
love you bub always and forever you'll
be in my heart on my ass maybe not so
much and then a couple pictures like i
thought i mean the best pictures ever
then the last one killed me where he was
like passing her like an apparel spread
yeah
the problem is is like it makes me like
annoyed at him because i i felt as a fan
of the show like so frustrated with him
over the last couple years it's like
your wife is
so much smarter than you so much much
more mature than you like she's always
right and like you don't listen to her
and you don't even like have the amount
of respect that you should have for your
wife right and so on one hand i'm like
extremely happy for katie i do think
like she's gonna
get into another relationship and see
like what it's really supposed to be
like right but when people have been
together for so long and we feel a part
of their journey like i do feel like a
twinge of sadness like i feel i feel
like it's the right thing to do
but i just i don't know why i feel so
invested it's i've been watching the
show i guess for
what is it eight to nine years well
that's the thing about katie and tom is
like they were so honest about the
relationship and their flaws i know
which made them relatable yeah but it
also you know made them victim to like
trolls totally and people saying really
mean things so i will say that i was
kind of holding out hope like i was like
maybe just do like a i was like maybe
just do a separation maybe right apart
maybe this the other and then when the
so i like i said i knew about a couple
weeks ago i got up there i obviously
started learning more about it but then
the rumor started and i was like [ __ ]
yeah because i knew i was going to get
asked like on the taylor striker show i
like people that work at people on my
show and i'm like damn it like and i
can't confirm anything but i also don't
like lying yeah of course so um and then
when we were out there um a new story
broke that like uh there had been
confirmation from james and the [ __ ]
dick and so and obviously like katie and
tom that's the thing too is what like
when i say
like they're like navigating this trying
to figure out how they're going like
they weren't withholding they were
figuring it out yes like they needed
like a second just like like even in
their own relationship talking through
right before they're making this like
public statement and then [ __ ] james
kennedy takes it from them he's such a
dick every time he makes like a little
progress on the show like you just
stepped forward three steps like when
he's commenting on their [ __ ] i'm like
get the [ __ ] out of here james yeah but
um but the very next day it was ocean's
first birthday and we were at jack's and
britney's for it they hosted it which
was very nice of that that was really
nice really nice but it was like very
like mermaidy themed it was really cute
how are jackson brittany doing they're
good good they're really good you know
you're at their wedding yeah yeah no but
i i mean i haven't seen them on tv in a
while right and so i just like
get that because like they all are so
themselves and they're so close in real
life yeah i like forget that they're not
on the show kristen
chris and dodie was there at the party
good i'm so glad i love these i had a
key a little kiki with raquel about
james oh what was james there no no he
was not good um she's thriving i
actually really like her after good she
was like making it a point to like kind
of say to people like i get that you
have an opinion about me from that and
like i get it too and like i'm a
different person now and i'm free so
good good for her sheena looked right
through me per usual
[Laughter]
saw sheena at the
academy of country music awards oh shut
up yeah and i saw brock too and i was
like shook by brock's girth in person
right yeah it is jason momoa yeah tay
maite who's a the a lesbian yeah was
like he is the hottest man i've ever
seen really they made me furious oh my
god i did never you know thought that
would be hey donna houston i know
right she likes the thicky thick thing
you are sick
so but no she actually we talked at the
end but um she has every right to look
through me i have talked nothing but
[ __ ] about her
at least you acknowledge that um but
yeah so but katie and shorts were there
and seemingly arrived together i mean
they live like around the corner they
still live together they're living
together right now yeah okay so um so
when i say it's amicable it's like
totally not [ __ ] like okay they show
up to the party they were like you know
a little sadder versions of themselves
but like they were still they're still
friends they still know the same friend
group i saw some people writing like
there's no way they could be broken up
because stasi was just seen like with
schwartz on sunday and she wouldn't do
that it's like no they're all best
friends of like 10 15 years yeah i mean
schwartz is gonna be
yeah i mean i mean
it's like their wedding now they the
bridal party was like super big before
but like now it's a much smaller guest
list
so it's a smaller bridal party but like
schwartz is still like very much a part
of like bo's
bridal group entourage yeah so no
they're actually it's it's amicable good
okay genuinely not [ __ ] it's so sad
but i do think it's the right decision
for everyone involved i know and i'm
looking forward to katie like getting
into when when the time is right like
getting into a new relationship and
seeing like wow
you know i could be valued i know i
could be with someone you know on my
level in terms of like emotional
maturity yeah and emotional intelligence
like
i'm excited she deserves that and they
both deserve to be happy happy exactly i
just i just honestly like i just don't
think that they are right for each other
honestly i agree and um i think that
they both actually see that now
yeah but i think that they'll still be
friends i really i i don't think it's
gonna end up like me and husband nobody
wants enemies
no i have so many i can i speak to that
very well okay next story is a
continuation on a story that's been
going on for literal months yeah kanye
west harassing and terrorizing everyone
speaking of enemies
kanye west has is worried pete davidson
will get kim hooked on drugs
so kanye west is now concerned about p
davidson's influence on kim kardashian
the easy designer went on a social media
tear against pete this wednesday
saying he's really concerned davidson
will get his ex-wife hooked on drugs he
said i'm really concerned that skeet
will get my kids moms hooked on drugs
he's in rehab every two months it's
unclear what made kanye discuss pete
davidson's history with drugs as a
comment he screenshotted that was the
picture was
the way skeet used kim's marital status
to address kanye was a sneak disc
towards her and she didn't even catch it
okay i can't he's it's every day it's
like a new story about his instagram
this is like you think it's like he
can't go any lower and then he goes low
like using someone's
substance problem
against them like that's just so low and
this whole situation like has just made
me like really fall in love with pete
davidson i agree the way he's just like
standing up for kim and like being such
a stand-up guy and like showing up for
the kids like and even being like when
he was texting kanye on sunday and
saying like dude i'll meet with you he's
a stand-up guy and he's like i have
mental health so do you so he like gets
it yeah but i mean connie is just out of
control i know and i when this whole
journey first started for kanye like
being an animal on social media at first
i was like you know what i don't think
we should discuss it he's obviously you
know mental health going through like a
bout of you know issues with his mental
health right but now it's just been so
long where like i'm so [ __ ] annoyed
at kanye like he might have lost me
forever like i'm so done with him he
will have me because of college dropout
like that album is my everything and
that also like ages me but whatever but
i do think that
especially with people like i had i have
live with mental health problems but
it's not an excuse to be like this
abusive right that actually is shining
such a light on it where i think we are
allowed to be like listen i just had um
this great guy jared lipscombe on my
um show and he is like a big part of
like the free britney movement and so a
lot of the free britney people are like
on team kanye
because of like kim stuff in the past
like it's very like twisted yeah and he
was saying like no i'm sorry but like
mental health issues are not a reason to
be like abusive towards other people
like they're like there is medication
there is help at his fingertips and
that's just something like condoms so
much access and then you think of like
right how this happens to like so many
women on like such a small scale and
they don't have like what kim has kim as
like you know round the clock security
and all these different like people who
work for and just all these
levels of protection and it's just like
it's not funny like i don't enjoy it
like talking about these stories
whatsoever like i really started to like
[ __ ] hate kanye he's he's you know
he's a control freak yeah we can see it
every single day that he's harassing
them it's abuse um it is and i'm just
happy she has pete and he's like
he really is
everything everything i know like what
this started out as like obviously like
a rebound of fling but like i'm now
feeling like these two could get married
like right no like the way he's the real
deal and they've been through now like
so much trauma together and that really
builds people to like bonds
relationships i can't see them long term
though i know i couldn't but like now i
can
maybe what what do you think the deal is
with him though because he has these
like fast and furious relationships and
then like it's like super hot and heavy
and they get engaged and then the second
they're engaged it burns out like
immediately right and it's like it's the
burning out on behalf of pete or over
the lady i mean it's right it's got to
involve him just some people
you know kate beck and sale ariana
grande yeah right like but this kim
thing has been going on since october so
it's not like nothing i don't know
do you feel like he got like is there
any world in which she just got like
cast for the new hulu shoe like hulu
like this is his job do not spew that
kardashian that is okay that [ __ ]
bothers me so much like how every like
everything it's you know what's so funny
it's actually really similar to what
people say about taylor swift like how
everything she does like has to be like
some sort of calculated thing for her
image like she's never just listening
can people just live
our lives no and like can i live yes you
can live because it's fine it's real
it's real did you see the trailer for
the hulu show yes i thought it looked
amazing i had chills chills everywhere
everywhere i've turned a corner on the
kardashians i'm like finally [ __ ] on
board okay oh my god i mean it's way
long overdue i know i shouldn't even be
allowed do you think it was internalized
misogyny from you being in the closet
[Laughter]
yes
okay now nobody can come for me right
right no like you have a reason
let me just trade my gay cloak over
myself
um okay next story is about rihanna
pregnant rihanna says she's in when
she's in her third time as no says she's
in her third trimester and she will be
psycho about protecting her baby so
rihanna's not playing around about her
baby on the way during a recent
interview with elle the pregnant 34 year
old singer opened up about her future
life as a mom sharing that she's entered
her third trimester well i thought she
was so much earlier on
the artist who's expecting her first
baby with asap rocky said that as a fan
of the real housewives franchise she
thinks her parenting style to be similar
to the real houses of new jersey's
teresa giudice oh geez teresa from
jersey does not play about her kids she
will flatten you about those kids and
that resonates with me a lot because i
feel like that's the type of mom i'm
gonna be psycho about it the grammy
winner grammy winner then quipped that
she'll actually be worse than judiciae
adding you'll talk about my kids it's
over oh my that's iconic that she
referenced the real housewives of she
loves bravo i know heather gay is her
favorite right is she yes heather gay
might be my least favorite housewife to
ever grace this we must discuss well i
will say this i've always loved heather
whitney i have like my finger on because
i can't quite tell with her i loved
heather and i really loved heather the
first season and she's had such a fall
from grace like she's the way she acted
this entire season was disgraceful and
embarrassing and beyond messy for me it
was the reunion that sealed the deal of
me being like come on heather get it
together no and you're better than this
whitney and heather were winnie's about
influence yes whitney and heather were
so out of control they actually made me
feel bad for lisa barlow me too i love
lisa barlow i kind of love her too she
can call me a [ __ ] all she wants yeah i
mean and i did [ __ ] half of new york
and i like ride or die wholeheartedly
for meredith marks
see that's where we have to differ yeah
mm-hmm do you really mean it's marx yeah
she's 100 right about everything tell me
what you did wrong and i'll fight you on
it um her outfit choice okay that's not
agreed
but see that's that's what someone would
say who doesn't have a legitimate gripe
i know i know i went low
do you have a legitimate grip with
meredith marks cause i'll fight you um
the way she speaks i mean she's a human
xanax again again low blow say something
concrete say something wrong she
actually did um was not a good
communicator about when her dad's uh
memorial was what the [ __ ] does she own
these women seriously what the [ __ ] does
she owe these women she just comes
across like and in the reunion i think
we we've she's hiding something when i'm
actually really she's not i think maybe
she just doesn't want to share her lives
with these women because they're [ __ ]
evil and they turn on each other every
10 seconds then as andy cohen said to
ramona then don't go on a reality tv
show right it's a job and i think she
participates she shows up to everything
mary shows up to nothing that's also
fair she shows up to everything and she
gives it a go she oh okay she was team
mary ride or die
the women left her out there to die with
her only life raft being ready i mean
remy i want mary every single woman on
the show like turned their back on her
she had no [ __ ] friends i guess so
we've we've seen a lot of housewives in
that debate dan meredith so hard because
she's right you know this makes me so
upset in our friendship because we are
always on the off like opposing side and
housewives bethany versus jill where
were you oh jill was at ocean's party
isn't that wild what i know i was like
shook um
i would say
back in the day yeah
oh it's so hard to transport back there
i guess i would have to say bethany but
like now in retrospect jill i was team
jail from the start
okay so i guess we're not totally on
opposite islands even no but even though
in the bethany versus jill saga
in the moment like jill was wrong like
she was just being so hard on bethany
right for like for what reason for what
she was like i'm the boss of you and you
know dude
dynamic shift did and jill wasn't ready
for it exactly um but back to riotta yes
what do you think about her pregnancy
style like everywhere she goes her
belly's out which i [ __ ] love i'm
here for it i think she's such an icon i
mean i just like can't believe that
someone gets to be her child i know the
depths of jealousy that i go into i'm
like so mad at my mom that she's not
rihanna you know i know how dare she
and your dad's not asap rocky oh how
dare my dad i mean i won't even speak to
him anymore because he's not a
billionaire oh like stop wasting my life
that might be one of the most [ __ ] up
things you've ever said
and that's like a long list of things
oh my god no you're right like rihanna's
baby's like just like so blessed um
and what do you think what is your like
now that you know two my sisters have
babies like i think about this a lot
like you know posting your baby on
social media and now like a lot of your
friends have a lot of games like what
are your thoughts on it you know i'm
like
i think i'm totally fine with it
especially moving forward i mean like if
i'm going to have this child in my life
and pay for all of its [ __ ] it needs to
pull its own weight and i can do so on
social media 100 you know so i that's
why i'm also very much here for it i
don't know i mean there's sometimes with
tays only because tay's sister is
private on instagram where like we post
our nephews and i get like pages of like
worry like i know does she care you're
she doesn't care but like i just get
nervous about it and then like i'm like
god forbid anything bad happened like it
was your fault so i guess
we shall see yeah like i'm very i'm very
cautious with other people's kids like
before i post about hartford i asked
aussie right always because now i'm like
in a family where we don't post our kids
on social media at home no how does how
does that i mean i totally respect it
especially when we've been through some
of these scandals that we've been
candles we've seen like a particularly
dark disgusting corner of the internet
yeah one that you would never want to
expose a child to um and i totally i
agree with their decision i just don't
know what i'm gonna do what do you think
rihanna is going to do i think it should
be protective as [ __ ] i think it's
becoming more and more um popular for
celebrities to not show their kids on
social media and i actually think it's
the right decision people are so [ __ ]
crazy and that's why she's showing her
stomach so much because she's like this
is the last time you see this baby and
you're never going to get another album
so ever ever
um we've got more stories for you and
they're brought to you by stamps.com
time is money don't waste either with
repeated trips to the post office with
stamps.com you can skip the trip and
focus on how to take your small business
to the next level stamps.com lets you
print official postage right from your
computer and it saves you money in the
process so you can spend less time at
the post office and more time making
your customers happy stamps.com saves
you time money and stress for more than
20 years stamps.com has been an
indispensable
resource for over one million businesses
they give you access to all the post
office and ups shipping services you
need right from your computer and you
get discounts you can't find anywhere
else like 40 off usps 76 off ups so
whether you're sending invoices you have
a side hustle etsy shop a full-blown
warehouse shipping out orders stamps.com
is here to make your life a little
easier all you need is a computer and a
standard printer stop overpaying for
shipping with stamps.com sign up with
promo code toast for a special offer
that includes a four week trial free
postage and a digital scale there's no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and enter code
toast
okay next story is oh okay i need to i
know you like are not familiar with the
flip flop drama i'm not but flipper flop
has officially been cancelled
thanks to tarek el moussa's complicated
love life okay oh so it's okay tarik
from like selling sunset yeah okay so
years ago there was this couple tarik
and christina elmusa and they had a show
called flipper flaw okay and they were
like a bargain basement version of chip
and joe like they have the tackiest
style their homes are heinous and they
like clearly hated each other
but like i think it did pretty well for
hgtv okay
then
one day like it was the perfect family
you know and they had like multiple kids
one day this news story comes out it was
like a live reporting from tmz tarek
fled the house wielding a gun stop went
into the mountains there was like a
helicopter chasing him it was chaotic
stop
chaos
then we never heard what happened like
it was just like silence and then they
shortly after got divorced okay well
yeah which was just like you know fans
of the show were like obviously this is
the end of the show it's like a couple
right but then they started to do the
show like as divorced parents and it was
like okay fine whatever they hate each
other a little bit less no like the show
totally went downhill but like they kept
the jig up okay then they both like
started having like the most bizarre
romantic lives like christina the wife
right has been like married and
divorced i think once or twice stop she
she was married to or yeah married to
aunt anstead who's now dating renee
zellweger jesus christ it's just so
weird now she's engaged to another guy
whose sister used to host a podcast with
heather ray young like no it's so
twisted and messy somebody once made a
tick tock of like all the relationships
they've had since they've got divorce
and how they're all like inextricably
linked are they torturing each other
through dating i don't know so and
they're just like so be honest
yes
really but
all this time the show has just like
limped along yeah
reflecting where they're at in their
lives but as of this week the show has
officially been cancelled are you
excited or sad i mean i haven't watched
the show in years it's literal trash
um but after nine years the x's target
and christina amusa have vaguely
announced that they are ending their
popular hgtv series flip or flop without
giving viewers a real reason why but now
page six says there seems to be one
christina who's now christina hack
initially said she was filled with
gratitude to have filmed 10 seasons of
the show but didn't mention her ex by
name in the social media post okay she
wrote bittersweet
news to announce it's the end of an era
next week's episode of flipper flop will
be the series finale oh wow she gave
fans like
no heads up heads up meanwhile tarek who
shares 11 year old and six-year-old with
christina right announced his
appreciation for the viewers who
supported him over the years and teased
a new project he said you watched me
beat cancer oh my god i didn't know that
you've watched the babies grow into the
most amazing amazing little humans and
everything in between but i'm not going
anywhere and i can promise you
that you're gonna love what comes next
so a source told the post that following
tark's marriage to heather l musa
staying on the show made things
complicated
the insider said it's not ideal to have
two exes who share children working
together so closely while their
significant others are just standing by
right el musa proposed to heather in
august 2020 and they just got married so
i guess is char trying to make it seem
like he's going to continue on the show
alone it's kind of how it sounds because
they're both they're both swinging
they're both horrible but tariq is 100
worse oh really well he was the one who
went into the mountains wielding a gun
well and he's the one who's always
yelling at christine on the show about
like her expensive tile
stop so yeah maybe him and um heather i
could see that because they they really
like ride or die for each other and they
work together as this like fame thirsty
couple so they're great for each other
and she's also like she knows from real
estate also like interior design a
little bit probably better than tacky
pants over there
that's actually a great point so maybe
she's just like sliding in oh my god
christina
will formerly el moussa now hack
will not be well no
deeply on because like tariq and
christina were like thirsty in their own
right but tarek and heather are next
level are 2.0 yep like beyond i mean the
people magazines drops every single day
like here is heather ray young's
favorite cupcake recipe like there is my
favorite nail polish color they're out
of control they could get written up
about they do heather young here's
what's in my purse like beyonce so
they're safe would you hear what's in my
purse but do you think their show would
be on netflix
yeah that's the other thing they're like
so hgtv you said yeah they're like level
up or discovery plus but i don't think
heather ray young could do both no she
probably would have to stay on netflix
right contractually speaking yeah and
they should they should do a show on
netflix honestly i'd watch the [ __ ] out
of it me too right heather has like
great style she really does great taste
great taste great taste you know great
taste right no what's up
do you want i can tell you when we're
done oh okay
my bridal shower
okay my first marriage oh okay was
literally like a hazing session at a
sorority it was horrible and there was
somebody at the shower who was like it
was like my family v his family
and every time i'd open a gift from her
people she would go like this
oh that's [ __ ] funny isn't it great
and every time i opened one from my
people it was like side eye central oh
one of my bridesmaids left crying and
said i've never felt fatter or poorer oh
and i said it's terrible
so now great taste well speaking of
netflix our final story they have a new
show netflix reality games is recruiting
the streamers unscripted stars to
compete against each other so the
reality worlds are colliding in a new
netflix competition series where fan
favorites from the circle love is blind
and too hot to handle are going ahead
going head-to-head on netflix reality
games the streaming service announced on
wednesday
their knowledge speed and strength will
be put to the test as they compete
against each other across three separate
events contestants include two hot to
handles francesca ferrago and harry
jousey okay the circles joey sasso and
delisa saint agath and love is blinds
lauren speed hamilton and cameron
hamilton oh and selling sunset star
christelle stouse will host the three
episode series which just launched on
netflix's youtube channel huh wow who
cares i thought it was gonna be on tv
youtube that's crazy oh and the teaser
it appears as though love is blind's
matt barnett hits the ground running
um and amber's there too i mean i love
the og cast of love is blind so i
actually don't watch the show but my
wife weirdly does because she refuses to
watch anything bravo right so she's a
huge fan but i will say this my boy do
you know chris burns fat carrie bradshaw
he's you need to meet him he's amazing
he just started a podcast with netflix
with one of the girls from love is blind
season one oh whoo
like if i could well it's called we have
the receipts i pulled it up while i was
asking here and i think her name's
lauren lauren speed hamilton
i'm looking at right now oh my god yes
lauren speed hamilton i [ __ ] love her
she was like the best she's married now
she's been married to someone she met on
the show for like a couple years now
it's really cute so but i feel like so
the whole show was about reality tv
shows on netflix right so i feel like
they're starting to kind of do this like
mtv real world rules challenges feeling
like the disney channel games like i
like it where everyone is like getting
on different teams and wearing the same
colors and competing and it feels a
little stupid and childish but we'll see
i mean it's a youtube show i didn't
realize i thought it was going to be on
the streaming service so yeah actually i
wonder why they're doing that like it's
just like i mean they've got some
serious slop on there so just throw that
on no it does they have such [ __ ] on
[ __ ] netflix and they're still not
going to renew the society for a season
too did you ever watch a society
it was one season of the literally the
greatest piece of television i've
probably ever watched it's about
apocalyptic thingamajigger yeah yeah
yeah yeah apocalyptic things
yeah um i won't spoil it for you but
it's about like this cast of high school
kids who end up in like the most twisted
parallel universe and it's like really
crazy okay
and we got left on such a cliffhanger
and the [ __ ] netflix cancelled it
like it's like the oa
i don't know what that is
i'm jealous actually but then i feel sad
because it's just like don't watch the
society and don't watch the way but if
you did like you know what i'm talking
about no it's so good and they've such
trash on there no thanks like the circle
give me a break give me a [ __ ] break
i know but it's society season two so
give me this don't put this on youtube
give me this on netflix yeah totally
like netflix has such weird priorities
did you see they announced they're doing
a um like a real in-person comedy
festival
how so they're gonna like they're doing
in la like three days of comedy it's
like a comedy festival like just for
laughs or oh [ __ ] really yeah is that
smart that's very smart because they're
really at the helm of like comedy like
if you get a netflix special like your
career is made i know on netflix yeah i
know it's crazy gotta get me one of
those we'll get you one of those working
on it yeah um okay well that was with
fast five taylor thank you for breaking
that down thank you for sharing some
inside scoop from the vanderpump rules
of it all and ocean's birthday party
ocean is la la's right yes i get
confused between ocean and summer
because their names are like natural
elements and they were born like on the
same day
is that fair that's totally fair
when i was a kid i used to be like hella
confused by julia roberts and sandra
bullock like they were the same person
no they're so not they're literally the
same person they're like brunette white
ladies
were there ever two celebrities julia
wait julia roberts she has red hair
like all the time wait i'm sorry lizzy
did you hear what taylor just said julia
roberts has red hair pretty woman that
was like her breakout roll she has red
hairs
what the [ __ ] are you talking about what
the [ __ ] are you talking about you know
what this is gonna be the thing that
ends our friendship literally julia
roberts has red hair um
yeah like not all the time but a lot and
sandra bullock has like super dark brown
hair okay i'm not gonna maybe julia has
light brown at times the thing is i'm
livid i can't even look at you i'm not
gonna defend like me as a child being
confused by these two ladies because
like sure it was confusing but i will
not back down on julia roberts having
red hair what the [ __ ] are you talking
about that's red that's okay first of
all we're looking at one picture where
she looks blonde well that yeah she's um
and by the way
when i was a kid she had like curly red
that's not red it's not dark brown
you guys let us know in the comments
does julia roberts have red hair
now we're going to dive into deer
toasters which is our advice segment if
you ever want to write in dear toasters
gmail.com is the email we will read your
prompt anonymously and we will do our
best to give non-judgmental advice but
no promises yes and dear toasters is
brought to you by canva pro making
content is an essential part of what we
do to keep the show going but hasn't
always been been a seamless creative
process so if you look at our instagram
you know the show is literally fueled by
canva pro it is the we don't have a
graphic designer it is the most seamless
way to make content for social for your
website it's easy you don't have to be a
graphic designer and ever since we found
canva pro we can do anything like a pro
designing on any device so canva pro is
a design platform that empowers you to
create and share stunning content in
just a few clicks designing with canva
pro is amazingly fast and fun choose
from thousands of templates that are
easy to customize or start from scratch
canva pro has endless premium fonts
photos videos and so much more
that add personality and edge to
whatever you're designing so we make all
of our guest cards on canva we make our
schedules while jackie's away they're
all being made on canva because not all
of us have a wife who's perfect at
design and video and everything some of
us have to do things ourselves
um and literally any graphic you see on
our instagram is made on canva neither
of us are true graphic designers canva
pro is the exact thing you need for your
business whether you're an influencer
you have an etsy store it's perfect um
their content planner also offers you
the ability to save time creating and
posting social media content too
you and your team can unlock everything
canva pro has to offer for just 12.99 a
month design like a pro with canva pro
and right now you can get a free 45-day
extended trial when you use promo code
go to canva.com sorry excuse me no
canva.me
slash toast to get your free 45-day
extended trial that's c-a-n-v-a
dot m-e slash
canva.me
toast to get the free 45-day extended
trial c-a-n-v-a
dot m-e slash toast okay i'm gonna get
it yeah by the way a million percent use
it for like your taylor striker show i'm
i should start it's literally all of our
like we don't have a graphic designer
everything we make and it takes four
seconds oh and they have an app you join
the computer or your phone okay perfect
it's everything okay
hey claudia and jackie well hey claudia
and taylor
i'm gonna cut right to it my boyfriend
and i have been together for almost five
years now and we've been living together
for the past two years he's 30 and i'm
25. up until i would say a year and a
half ago i started to notice that my
brothers who are 31 and 27 feel some
type of way about my boyfriend didn't
think too much into it but then one of
my brothers pulled me aside and asked me
if everything was okay i was taken aback
because yeah everything was totally fine
he laid out his concerns about my
boyfriend saying he's controlling and i
don't come around much anymore keep in
mind i have a full-time job i live about
45 minutes outside of the city with no
car and my one brother lives close to my
parents and the other brother lives with
my parents still oh so of course they're
all seeing each other right i told my
brother it's not as easy for me to come
back to the suburbs every time with
every time that a random plan pops up we
moved on from the convo and then about a
year later we are at my brother's
wedding overseas and i know my boyfriend
was beyond drunk and stupid and very
annoying but all of a sudden my parents
also mention how they've had enough of
my boyfriend let's call him bob so now
i'm an emotional wreck one woman i'm
annoyed with with how my boyfriend is
acting
i'm annoyed with how my boyfriend is
acting drunk to finding out all my
friends and family feel like they don't
like my boyfriend anymore now this is my
dilemma i love my family and i take what
they say seriously but i feel like it
has affected my relationship i feel like
i cannot move on without both sides
being happy and all getting along but i
also do not want him out of my life if
some sort of understanding does not
happen please help what side do you take
when family and boyfriends don't get
along sincerely a confused and saddened
toaster i mean this is tough because
you're obviously like in the
relationship so
are you saying your relationship's
totally fine because it is or because
you're delusional and you're being
controlled like you know right exactly
like i i have to assume that your
family's never coming from a bad place
yeah but but not a bad place but maybe a
selfish place and a lot of times it's
easier to blame the new partner or even
the long-term partner than it is to
actually like blame the person in the
relationship right like you're not
coming around because you live 45
minutes away and everyone lives on the
same block like that has nothing to do
with your boyfriend nothing but it's
easy to point the finger right and then
like if he gets drunk once and it's like
he's the drunk one it's like they can't
let it go i also hate when people make
just like blanket statements like he's
controlling really when how just give me
an example so like how i was with
meredith marks they hate his outfits
right exactly it's like give me
something concrete so you know what i
feel like as much as you probably are
avoiding these conversations like why
don't you sit down with them and be like
okay what are you talking about cause
i'm not seeing what you're seeing so
give me some examples of how he's
controlling when you felt like i was
being controlled right when he wasn't
being a good partner you can't just say
these blanket statements without proof
i've been every not surprisingly i've
been in every single role that we've
just heard in that one scenario so like
i have had okay so i was married i've
definitely been the partner that was
disliked by the family with husband
great taste um i wonder why they didn't
like me um
i mean we were everybody had skin in the
game on that one but my parents started
to not like him
in addition to like the fighting with
his family but he would always do this
thing where we would because we're from
new york right so we would be around
boston visiting my parents and it's like
a six hour drive back so we would leave
and he'd be talking about our dinner
reservations on a sunday night and my
mom felt like he was excited to leave
yeah and i was like no he's just excited
about dinner that's like our life is
food and then we fight and then we eat
food and that's like how we survive
and
but she felt like he was being rude
because she was so sad that we were
leaving i mean it is like it is but she
was like before him you'd stay till like
late at night and i was like well that's
because i was i was like you'd decide
for me right and now after him i still
like want to leave at a certain time and
i still want to eat food on sunday night
yeah so that's the thing it's like i
can't fully blame him like my mom
thought my now wife was a seductress
when we first got together
and was taking advantage of me in my
like new divorce say so like that's the
thing is families can be well
intentioned but [ __ ] wrong that's
true that's definitely true so
don't like it especially if you like
your partner a lot and it's really good
just between the two of you there's
really no need to like just don't end it
because of your family like you also
there's a role that you have to play in
like sticking up for your partner like
sometimes like with tay's like friends
oh my god she had this big friend group
and i love them but they're in like now
but in the beginning tay was like
everybody's closeted lesbian like
girlfriend right so when i came around
she was like no longer available to them
and they resented me for it but like it
wasn't me but i'm sure they were like
taylor struckers controlling she's never
around anymore it's her fault right so
when you're in a relationship like i
don't know it depends on on who it is
and what it is but like you're supposed
to spend the majority of your time like
with that person yeah it's like healthy
and normal right right yeah so i would
definitely continue asking questions
never stop asking questions but don't
unless they really give you a good
reason sounds like you haven't gotten a
good reason to doubt your relationship
at all no and getting drunk one night
doesn't count i agree like we've all
having still been there we've all been
the person at a wedding who needed to be
carried upstairs by the mayor of a major
city yeah that happened to me i mean i i
nearly like took jackie's wedding down
oh you did
i threw chanel bag cara lagerfeld died
two days later
like in an uber like no i think no my
wife left me at the wedding i sat at a
table with heather mcmahon and her man's
and cried and flirted with your male
cousins oh good good i was a [ __ ] show
oh my god you know what's so funny like
there was so much going on at the
wedding like nobody even noticed you're
fine i harassed um a pop icon we'll
leave it at that yeah yeah um okay good
good good good
moving on
hello claudia and taylor long time
listener first time writer i don't even
know how to start this so the deer
toaster from before the maternity leave
made me brave enough and i decided to
write in
for context i'm married and absolutely
in love with my husband for the last
year we've been exploring our sexual
fantasies and we've both expressed
wanting a threesome
oh so before sorry before we went on
maternity leave somebody had written in
being like this you know got she's
crushed at this guy at work and like he
asked if she would have a threesome with
he asked if he if she would have a
threesome with him and his wife okay and
so she was she was the um the extra yes
and so i was all for it i'm like girl
you're young just like you might have to
leave your job afterwards but like if
you don't like your job it's fine right
and jackie was like don't do it don't
mix business with pleasure jackie was
just being like conservative queen but i
was like go for it so that's what she's
referring to okay
um me more so than my husband were into
the idea he is more into the watching
game but will participate if that's what
i want the conundrum is that i'm
terrified of my public presence we're
not famous by any means but oh my gosh
what if someone i know is on one of
those apps we recently joined one and
even paid for a membership getting a lot
of likes on our photos with our faces
blurred and i'm still too chicken [ __ ]
to message people back we don't want a
relationship with anyone purely just a
night of fun i trust my partner and he
trusts me so why am i freaking out even
though i initiated this i know it's not
something y'all partake in but any
advice for a wannabe wild woman i just
feel like this would be so fun but i'm
so anxious for some reason sincerely i
want to be a wild one okay so i am a
conservative queen as well yeah
shockingly i know conservative queen in
practice but like i really encourage
other people to live their best most
wild lives
i'm just so jealous i can't even like
begin to think about sharing in the
bedroom so like i don't even understand
how it would even go right well you also
have a different dynamic because this
girl's in a hetero relationship right
but i mean like when she's saying i mean
if
i would take a straight man into our
relationship if he paid the bills and
wanted to watch us have sex but that's
where it ends brian kelly
but um i mean listen she's curious
enough to like take those steps so
obviously there's a desire there the
only reason she hasn't followed through
with this because she's nervous she'll
see someone that she knows on this app
but guess what that person's also on the
app yeah so you have nothing to be
ashamed of no it's like just do it no
where you know what drive like an hour
outside your city like go to a bar like
do with the real like the you know the
fashion way the old-fashioned way if
you're a stranger if you're nervous
about seeing someone on the app even
though i didn't know they made apps for
that
i didn't either what's it called well
the thing though is
really maybe you'll find claudia on
there
[Laughter]
literally no by the way the thing is
like i could never have a threesome no
no
first of all i'm like so unbelievably
jealous and i'm saying so unbelievably
famous like everyone would be talking
about that so i see i'm so unbelievably
jealous and so unbelievably insecure
like nobody can see me naked if you had
oh by the way that's the real reason i
will never have a threesome if by some
mat like if if i wake up one day it's
like freaky friday and i wake up in the
body of like a sickening model sure i'll
have a million threesomes until that day
absolutely not
um if you had to like gun to your head
if you had to bring someone into a
relationship
for one night like a bet in the bed
would you bring
a man or a woman
oh a man
both a man
you'd be okay with that
um
i would bring in a man because i'm so
competitive right so like we have to
bring in the dangling so that way
there's like i'm not comparing my body
right um i
i have a really good friend from
kindergarten is that who you want to
bring in and he just got married this
past like fall and after the wedding we
he married a man um and we played spin
the bottle
and i was so jealous there weren't even
words so like happened
we just they were just like i i've never
played spin the bottle in my entire life
like you guys i could barely handle
gay guys and gay women playing spin the
bottle great so did you have to kiss
anyone yep i got to kiss my friend chris
was it passionate and it was kind of
like everything because we knew each
other since we were in kindergarten and
we were in love in kindergarten but we
weren't allowed to kiss in kindergarten
no tongue i don't do tongue i said say
no [ __ ] time
who didn't take this she got to kiss
chris's husband zenin was just the four
of you he's gonna [ __ ] kill me that
i'm saying their names was it just the
four of you no it was like a lot of
people from the morning oh my that
actually sounds so fun it was fun but
also not do you know what i'm saying i
would leave crying like if ben kissed
anyone i would seriously like die but so
afterwards tay was like well because we
want to have kids and we're going to
look at sperm donors yeah and she was
like well if we want to have kids with
chris and zennan we could do with the
old fashioned way right biggest fight of
our life
so as i say a man even a gay man i could
get in a fight with that is so funny and
i saw chris recently and i was like
if we come they're gonna be like in
france i was like if we come to france
we like no no joke like don't even joke
about an orgy right and he was like no
after spin the bottle i understand like
you're psychotic because then both of
you get pregnant and then you can both
have babies for both of you i know right
it'd be so cute i know but i can't
handle it no of course not but anyway
live your best life girl
yeah i think just like if it's something
you really want to do like just do it
and if you're worried about seeing
someone else on the app just remember
that person's also on the app they're
worried about seeing other people
they're not going to be looking at you
they're going to be like is anyone
looking at me it's fine just do it it's
obviously fantasy of yours and i feel
like you'll be really excited after it's
done yeah do it also if you do it can
you let us know how it went yeah so we
always encourage people to write in with
updates they never do
but it's so [ __ ] annoying they just
leave us hanging let's write us in with
an update
all right here's our third and final
okay
i'm seeking some friendship advice i've
met my friend almost two years ago out
drinking one night for some background
i'm in my mid-20s and my friend anna is
in her early 30s anna recently broke up
with her toxic boyfriend and moved out
of his apartment to live by herself
before moving out we probably saw each
other every other weekend now that she
lives by herself all of her free time
isn't consumed by him she's been up my
ass and i cannot handle it she texts me
every single day and sometimes multiple
times a day i'm not the biggest texter
you love the look i have a long distance
boyfriend and we don't even text as
frequently as she texts me the texts
have uh have started to give me the
friendship ick it's really the only way
i can describe it i got this term from
watching too much love island every
little thing is starting to annoy me
with her now and i don't know what to do
do i just start ignoring her texts i've
tried this before and she then she
thinks i'm mad at her i don't think i
feel comfortable telling her
because i don't want her to think that
i'm not there for her i attached a
recent text thread so you can see what i
mean any advice is appreciated okay
the girl wrote hope you had a good night
wish you guys were here tomorrow night
love you sleep well
that's at thursday 9 50. okay friday 5
20 p.m hi baby
saturday 9 13.
hope you're having a good weekend my
babe
sunday 11 56. love you
yeah that's like that's like a guy who
like wants
that's really like like that's oh wow
that's the thing
[Laughter]
in this life there's two kinds of people
people who have overwhelmingly blue text
messages and people who have
overwhelmingly great text messages if
your message threads with your friends
and family are all blue meaning you're
the one who sent them like you need to
reevaluate your life and like spend less
time on your phone and maybe realize
people in your life like don't [ __ ] with
you and if you have so many great
messages that's like oh man i'm so
popular maybe i should respond to more
people in a timely fashion
how many unopened text messages do you
have on your phone right now today yeah
want to take a guess yeah
yes 764.
more
1212. oh my god that's psychotic you
want to know how many i have
11 because they've acquired while i've
been sitting here and i'll open them
after and respond to them accordingly um
listen a lot of that's from like drizzly
i order a lot of alcohol yeah i know but
why don't you just open them and then
like why do you have to leave them
unopened i feel like they're like
somehow they're going to hack my
identity
you are showing your age here at the
morning toast
oh man well let's have this girl like
the thing is do you want to be friends
with this girl in perpetuity or you've
seen what you've seen and you're good
like because if you're done with her
just stop answering but that is kind of
rude to like leave someone and when
they're going through a hard time i know
you could be next you know like it's
always easy to be like high and mighty
when things are going well for you but
you know we're all like minutes away
from an impending something losing our
job breakup mental breakdown and so like
yeah if you're not there for the people
in your life who are going through a
hard time
they're not going to [ __ ] be there
for you either and karma's a [ __ ] and
nothing i always think when things are
going well for me i'm like oh something
bad's about to happen like i know and
you know like something bad like went on
in my personal life like
like
like eight months ago
and now i feel like oh my god it's only
been eight months since like something
bad has happened to me like i'm ready
for my next bad thing oh god i know i
get it it's a terrible way to live i
feel like maybe develop some sort of a
system like you can take the weekends
off but then like give her like a phone
date like i don't want to go like a once
like a fair sign yeah give her maybe
something because she's going through it
right now but like i also understand
like especially on the weekends yeah
just so she's reaching out because she
like needs someone to talk to like isn't
that sad but that's yes it's sad but
it's also responsibility and obligation
is like like nothing triggers me more
than obligation a burden like i love a
[ __ ] that's like hey
let's do something but also we also
don't have to yeah i also love a
friendship and i feel like our
friendship is like totally we never need
to talk we really don't talk never but
then it's like we'll have to go for like
you know a bi-monthly meal to catch up
on everything yes but then we do yeah
and i just don't really believe like
friendships
if you live in the same city as a person
friendship should be maintained via text
message like you don't need to be
texting your friends all that much
unless there's like something going on
it's like let's go out to eat we'll
catch up on everything we could have
texted about for a week yep i had a
friend from college we're not friends
anymore i asked her to please downgrade
me because she required too much yeah
and there was a point where she was
going through something hard genuinely
hard a parent was passing away it was
awful horrible horrible and one of our
mutual friends like said to me hey um
something just happened um there was
like addiction involved so that's like
why it was like such a long drawn out
thing and my friend was like oh
something bad happened with so-and-so's
parent just text her so i texted i said
hey so-and-so told me about something
that happened how are you and she said
to me
you know that's really annoying that
someone had to tell you and i said why
i'm like i didn't know like if you need
me please let me know and i will be
there for you and she was like no i need
friends that check in so frequently that
they know what's what i'm going through
and i said well girl like i i want to be
there for you but i can't like change my
complete genetic major right yeah so
some people are like that like and i
have a lot of friends who i actually
feel bad who like text all the time like
they're so good and like if it weren't
for them like maybe we'd never keep in
touch but like for me i'm just not that
girl like text me we'll go to lunch and
we'll catch up on everything yeah if you
need me you need to let me know you need
me yeah me too and i and i'm never shy
about like telling my friends like i
need you to show up to this exactly um
so with this girl like i just just
evaluate where you want to
have this friendship be at but also
don't be a [ __ ] because she's obviously
going through yeah yeah exactly want to
kill you to have a little compassion
maybe give her like i don't know what
should she give her once a week xanax
in person hang once a week that's a lot
we don't even hang out that much anymore
i know so what should she give once a
week phone call fine for like the next
two months face time yeah zoom face time
why because you could like you know
answer emails but also like still being
you know exactly and you have to like
walk out your front door right right
which is the worst the hardest part
um well that was your toasters and if
you guys ever want to write in the email
is dear toasters gmail.com
that's how you can get to us and we'll
always keep your [ __ ] anonymous and
we'll try our best to give good healthy
advice that is our show yes that was
taylor strecker on the toast she will
definitely be back
while jackie's on maternity leave so
tomorrow we've got sophia franklin and
the next day we have josh peck so it's a
great lineup for the rest of the week
taylor your queen if you guys like what
you heard here the taylor strecker show
on patreon is two hours of daily radio
monday through friday it's patreon.com
the taylor striker show yep amazing and
follow taylor on instagram she needs the
followers please and i love you guys
thank you so much for listening to the
morning shows the monday morning show
julia roberts does not have red hair
thank you so much for listening
if you're watching this episode on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as podcasts and we're
podcasts can be found so it's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i have
radio cast box all the places wherever
you listen to podcast find out this
morning toast leave a five star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are taylor i love you toasters i love
you have an amazing day and we'll see
you tomorrow happy hump day bye